okay great um i'll be talking today
about confounding robust policy
evaluation in infinite horizon offline
reinforcement learning
so the motivation of this work is going
to be studying of offline reinforcement
learning and you can think about this as
infinite horizon longitudinal causal
inference
and some aspects of this
problem regime broadly speaking are that
we don't know the underlying dynamics of
the system reinforcement learning
terminology we we say that we don't have
a perfect simulator and so that means
that many model based approaches or
correspondingly g computation or
other approaches that make functional
form assumptions can lead to bias
estimation and secondly this is a very
offline
situation where we're doing causal
inference with observational data
because running online experiments can
be very costly and unsafe in stark
contrast to the rest of reinforcement
learning in general which is about
online experimentation and so there's
been a number of recent works that look
towards offline reinforcement learning
or dynamic treatment regimes and
longitudinal causal inference in order
to learn
optimal sequential treatment policies
from this kind of
trajectory data collected from
individuals over time
and so i'll be talking today about the
infinite horizon setting so this cartoon
of patient trajectories just depicts
what you might what kind of data set you
might be working with in an infinite
horizon setting this y-axis is
the patient's glucose state so we're
monitoring it over time in a kind of
continuous monitoring
setting and we see some time
we see the time dependence on the x-axis
and you may be working with a series of
such patient trajectories that were
collected under some kind of
observational treatment collection
assignment um and so this could be the
doctor's uh decisions um
[Music]
a doctor's decisions um practice as
usual it could be what is called in
reinforcement learning under some kind
of behavior policy but we're going to
focus specifically on the challenge of
unobserved confounding so there could be
additional information or additional
unobserved confounding you that informs
the historical treatment assignment
decision but it's not actually recorded
in your data
and this is pretty common this can be
pretty common in healthcare settings
because many of the data sets that
people work with were really collected
for convenience and so
this happens in practice that people
use these data sets or these
observational data sets there's this
very famous
database that was a lot of people went
into a lot of effort to make this
publicly available but it's essentially
just the collection of electronic
medical records and so the evidence of
efficacy for these policies is
essentially exactly based on this kind
of statistical evaluation
of you know these kinds of
counterfactual means from this
observational data precisely in settings
where we know that the assumptions that
justify longitudinal causal inference
are probably untrue so that's a kind of
broad high level motivation this talk is
going to be about obtaining partial
identification bounds under very
restricted model so we're not going to
handle the full complexity of these
problem settings but i'm going to
provide a very high level overview
of how we
how we can obtain these kinds of robust
bounds so the general idea is that we're
going to reason about what it is that we
could do
if we had access to all of the
information
the full information data
and we're going to focus on the kinds of
estimation we might do
building on offline reinforcement
learning if we had access to all of the
information the observed states and the
unobserved confounders of course the
challenge is that we don't have access
to all of this information our
observational data sets
con
omits the unobserved confounder and of
course we can't get something for free
in this type of setting so we're going
to have to add additional assumptions so
first of all we're going to have to
impose additional structural
restrictions on the underlying latent
dynamics
that generated the data and so this will
position a certain kind of graphical
restriction or assumption on the
unobserved confounding
and we're going to obtain robust bounds
by essentially lifting or optimizing
over a sensitivity model from causal
inference which the basic logic is about
relating what we don't observe the how
the
actions were obtained
conditional on unobserved relative to
what it is that we can observe so the
outline of the talk is just going to be
about describing these components
and telling you how we obtain our bounds
essentially at a very high level about
maximizing or minimizing a statistical
estimator
such that the unobserved components of
the statistical estimator
are valid probability distributions
compatible with their observational
distribution and consistent with the
additional assumptions that we're
imposing here so for the rest of this
talk i'm first going to go through the
problem set up more formally about
offline reinforcement learning introduce
the precise structural restrictions we
use
i'll walk through the development of
this method for obtaining robust bounds
by talking about the estimator the
sensitivity model
and then i'll talk about our results
which are more about characterization so
about ensuring validity that we can
optimize over these
over these optimization variables and
relate that ultimately to the set of
mdps that was generating our observed
data
so i'll start with the problem setup
and so i'm going to uh posit that the
data came from
what is what was an infinite horizon
markov decision process on a full
information state space the product
space of s and u so s is the observed
state space it's going to be restricted
to be discrete and u is a space of
unobserved confounders which can be
quite general
so
the underlying dynamics are a bona fide
markov decision process we observe
trajectories omitting this unobserved
confounder information and it was
ergotic on this full information state
space
in case anyone is unfamiliar the
decision protocol is simply that at a
given full information state smu you
receive some reward that is dependent
only on the observed state you take an
action a in our observational data
depending uh on both the observed and
unobserved
confounders that's where the unobserved
confounding comes from
and you transition to the next state s
prime u prime with some transition
probability defined on the full
information state space
now intuitively the so far i haven't
described any restrictions from a normal
mdp except for that the rewards depend
only on the observed state
later on i'll describe exactly the uh
what we are assuming but you should just
think about this as we're going to
consider unobserved confounding
that is exogenously generated at every
time step so there is no dependence
between unobserved confounders at
different time steps and you can think
about this a little bit like the reverse
of a palm dp so in a palm bp you have
this hidden stake
you have this hidden state it emits
exogenous observations and your reward
depends on the hidden state in contrast
in our model the unobserved confounder
affects both actions and the transitions
to next states so transitions are
confounded but it doesn't affect the
rewards and so you don't necessarily
want to conduct inference on the hidden
state
okay so i'm going to introduce some
objects
that make estimation easier in the
infinite horizon setting
so for fixed time step
t
we're going to define the empirical
joint distribution of state action
next state uh frequencies
um and so this this is just the
frequency with which you observe a
certain kind of uh transition tuple now
the time limit of these empirical
distributions is what yields the
stationary state action state occupancy
distribution or the kind of stationary
probabilities of observing these
transition tuples now when you
marginalize these full information
occupancy distributions
the you can recover what is more
familiar as the stationary distribution
on the chain induced by some policy pi
so i'm going to call p infinity for some
policy pi the full information state
occupancy distribution and of course you
can further marginalize this to simply
the observed states now you can define
these stationary distributions under the
behavior policy and the
evaluation policy so you can pick pi to
be e or b
you you observe the
observed state marginalized distribution
under the behavior policy but of course
you don't know it under the evaluation
policy so the target s demand in this
infinite horizon setting can be written
as an average or an expectation of your
rewards with respect to the stationary
distribution
under the evaluation policy now this is
different from the finite horizon
setting because a lot of the
identification results rely on
sequential importance sampling what's
important here is that we have an
expectation with respect to one
distribution namely that of the
stationary distribution
um and so this is the estimation
strategy that recent work of flue at all
2018 take in the infinite horizon case
and we're going to build um on this
particular estimation strategy and
consider robustness with respect to it
and so this estimation strategy
focuses instead on trying to estimate
the density ratio w
defined on the full information states
which is simply the density ratio in the
stationary distributions
and this is in general a market
improvement from trying to do uh
stepwise importance sampling or so on
which would otherwise incur products of
these density ratios for every single
time step so this is the main difference
in the stationary or infinite horizon
setting so these statistical estimators
typically try to estimate this w density
ratio function and then simply evaluate
or estimate the
the policy value by taking averages over
the observational stationary
distribution which again you
you observe so
to briefly talk about related work the
main difference is that most work on
offline policy evaluation or estimating
counter factual means and dynamic
treatment regimes assume sequential
ignorability for identification with the
exception of assuming certain kinds of
graphical structures that can permit
identification under latent variables
and so
we are going to focus on establishing
partial identification in this very
specific model in the infinite horizon
setting
there is work a lot of work
a lot of work on partial notification a
lot of it considers the single time step
setting when it comes to these kinds of
optimal treatment regimes
and for a very abridged comparison to
some related work mostly from offline
reinforcement learning you can think
about this as really
focusing on these density ratio
improvements when it comes to
handling uh unobserved confounders in
the sequential setting there are a
variety of other kinds of ident
identifying assumptions so there is a
lot of other kind of structure that can
be available you can make model based
assumptions and posit some kind of
invariable
model a prior or a deeply invariable
model on the unobserved confounding
those will come with certain kinds of
identification assumptions you can use
proximal inference in a in a true palm
dp
that also will impose some kinds of rank
restrictions and so you can think about
this as just adding another
complementary set of structural
restrictions under which you can obtain
partial identification
so um to conclude this
section about the setup the structural
restrictions i mentioned that you should
think about this intuitively as the
exogenous confounders are generated
exogenously at every time step
the reason for this is because we are
effectively assuming that the density
ratio the full information density ratio
is a function only of the observed state
and of course a sufficient condition for
this to be true is when the exogenous
con is when the unobserved confounders
are generated in this way
so i've described the structural
restrictions and now i'll talk a little
bit more in detail about the estimation
strategy and what's important is that it
has this very simplified dependence on
what it is that we don't know about our
data namely the dependence of the on the
unobserved confounders so
to briefly summarize this estimation
approach
there's this very nice
development from lou at all so in if you
had sequential unconfoundedness or if if
you only had these observed states
the way to think about this is that they
provide a
conditional moment
identifying estimating equation for the
density ratio conditional on the next
state
where this comes from intuitively is
that let's start with the um
with what we know about this a
stationary distribution so a density
ratio is a ratio of stationary
distributions the stationary
distribution
satisfies a system of equations namely
that when you evaluate it against the
transition matrix you again obtain the
stationary distribution
now in particular that's a single time
step expectation over a transition and
when you unroll this expectation
they do it in this backwards fashion you
can intervene on the action distribution
so you intervene with these important
sampling weights and that's how you
obtain this kind of what is called
backwards flow equation so that's the
intuition for how they are able to
obtain an estimating equation for the
density ratio that most importantly
relies on
taking an expectation over a single
transition that depends on the quantity
that we don't know the inverse
probability of taking decisions which
i'm going to call beta for short
so our first characterization is that
essentially by construction
the
we can estimate the density ratio
by solving this estimating equation if
we knew the true functional form of beta
and the observations of unobserved
confounders which of course we don't but
we're going to be robust with respect to
those but this already buys us something
because we don't have to solve a
conditional moment on the uh on both the
observed and the unobserved state space
so in a sense that's essentially why we
made these structural restrictions or
you can think about it as if this is
true this is a kind of simplification of
estimation as a simpler robust
dependence so i mentioned that this is
this tells us what we could estimate if
we knew the
if we knew
how the behavior policy was taking
actions conditional on observed and
unobserved of course we don't know that
and so here's where the kind of very
traditional ideas about sensitivity
analysis and causal inference come come
into play because we've essentially
identified an estimator that depends on
this unknown probability of taking
actions in a very simplified way we
didn't we didn't try to recover the
relationship between the observed and
the unobserved confounder or the
functional form and so these very
agnostic assumptions are exactly what
the sensitivity model from causal
inference
is going to
parametrize
so this uh the sensitivity model that we
use
simply provides a convenient
parametrization because we're optimizing
any linear uncertainty set could be
substituted for this
and so we follow the marginal
sensitivity model of tan which bounds
the odds ratios of selection into
treatment
under the full information relative to
what you can observe conditional and
only the observed state uniformly by the
sensitivity parameter gamma
and now
because this holds uniformly over
over functions and over these unknown
realizations of u but without imposing
parametric restrictions this essentially
means that when we take this
optimization point of view we're going
to
obtain these kinds of interval bounds on
the value that this optimization
variable can take
and when we compute these empirical
expectations we're going to have these
point wise bounds that can vary for
every
optimization variable corresponding to a
data point in our data set
okay so what we do
is that we study this problem a little
more closely and because we are working
with a finite state space we can
actually optimize or we can
re-parameterize this optimization
over a certain marginalization so we're
going to define this g variable which is
the marginalization of this inverse
probability weight with respect to an
unknown but possibly adversarial
transition distribution
and we can verify that the same
restrictions implied by the previous
sensitivity model can equivalently be
imposed on this
on this new reparametrized optimization
variable and the the most important
thing is that the dimensionality of this
reparameterization depends only on the
size of our problem on the cardinality
of the state space instead of scaling in
the size of my data set
okay so to put it all together what we
say is essentially that you can compute
these upper and lower bounds by solving
what is admittedly a hard non-complex
quadratic program you optimize over
these g variables and the estimation
variables w
you optimize over the sensitivity model
over the validity requirements that it's
an inverse probability distribution and
you optimize over your partially
identified estimating equation so this
is a kind of strange robust bi-level
problem it's generically a non-complex
quadratic program it's bi-linear
but when it comes to computation um
because we've repented
re-parameterize it to depend on the size
of the problem jirobi can solve this for
small instances and so that's what i'll
show you at the end
so i've described the method
i've told you how we put these pieces
together we ultimately write this down
as a non-convex quadratic program
and i'll talk a little bit about some of
the subtleties
in studying sharpness or relating
this optimization that we're doing in
the space of
restrictions
on the
estimating equation back into ensuring
validity for all mdps compatible with
our observational distribution
um and so i'll talk about this
kind of at a high level
but i i said that we want to make sure
that we're optimizing
over these inverse probability weights
that are compatible with the
observational distribution
so far the only thing that i haven't
accounted for is that the adversarial
behavior policy that i'm optimizing for
is stationary with respect to my
observed observational stationary
distribution
um and so essentially what's funny about
this problem relative to other
sensitivity analysis and causal
inference
is that if you study what is known in
the mvp literature about the valid
state action state polytope of occupancy
distributions this is very classical
it's used to study regularity conditions
for mvps
it's that you can't actually enforce
this equation
we've added the constraints from the
sensitivity model that exhaust the
observable implications
instead
really what is enforcing validity is the
combination of the sensitivity model and
the estimating equation so that's a kind
of subtle
inside baseball note on how this
compares to sensitive analysis and
causal inference something interesting
is that you can be infeasible
for small value you can be infeasible
in the setting for values of a
sensitivity parameter so your data can
reject
the sensitivity model because of these
violations of stationarity or
compatibility
okay so again when it comes to
computation
it's non-convex
i derive like an alternating
minimization approach but there's not
much that can be said about it
because we have this reparameterization
it's actually it's actually solvable in
practice for very small examples
and when it comes to statistical
consistency so far everything i've said
assumes that we plug in true
distributions of course these are
estimated from data you compute
the empirical joint distributions um and
we show that as your the distributions
that you plug in converge so too do
these robust bounds
now unfortunately uh to prove this we
had to
um we had to
because we were thinking about it as a
perturbation analysis of optimization
programs and perturbation analysis of
left-hand side constraints
is a little is much less quantified
relative to other kinds of perturbations
and so this uses a very general
variational analysis results which is
about the stability of optimization
problems to perturbations in general
okay so i'll
describe a very small example just to
show what these bounds look like
and so i mentioned that you can solve
this with gerobi for very small
instances and so here's a small instance
we have a small 3x3 windy grid world
you start in a start state you
go to you want to get to the green goal
state
along the way there are some dangerous
red states and the wind comes into play
because with some probability the wind
will blow you into the dangerous state
now an unobserved confounding could
arise if you had a forecast of the wind
and so essentially
what this means is that an optimal
policy on the full information state
space is going to take actions that
depend on the unobserved confounder and
so this is a way of introducing an
observed confounding now on the right we
show the bounds
as we go from green to orange we're
trying to evaluate policies that are
closer to optimal so they deviate
further from
uniform
and so as we go from green to orange our
bounds become more and more ambiguous
they become looser and this reflects
that if we're trying to go further from
the distribution that generated the data
there's more ambiguity
there's more ambiguity and the bounds
become looser and so in general these
robust partial identification bounds you
can think of as
they can be quite loose and so they're
either uninformative
or they encourage you to collect more
data invest in running a
sequential randomized trial or in good
cases like this green case
they can still be informative decisions
because these bounds still
bound you dv uh uniformly away from zero
and so i'll just conclude there so again
the goal is to reflect fundamental
ambiguity rather than spurious precision
and there are interesting open problems
inference is really important but
because of all of this non-convexity
it's much harder to establish
statistical inference and there's other
interesting questions about sharpness
and finite sample trade-offs as usual
okay
thank you
ah there it is okay hi angela thank you
it's very interesting talk uh just a
quick question so you've chosen a
particular
sensitivity analysis strategy for an
observant founding and of course there
are lots of them right so you picked the
one by rosenbaum
there are other likes based on tilting
and all sorts of things like that so is
there any particular advantage to
picking the one you chose for what
you're doing versus other things
yeah that's a great question
um
there's not a very specific advantage
relative to the tilting based approaches
this is much less about conducting
inference or
or estimating
or doing inference under some
kind of model of how the you were
generated and so in some sense
most of these results are
fairly agnostic to which sensitivity
model you choose so long as it is
linearly representable so so convex um
restrictions
on the
on the beta variables are difficult
computationally but linear is fine so
these results are not very specific um
to which kind of restriction so but you
also mentioned that the the
the solver that you end up you can only
do toy problems with this so is it quite
obvious that if i picked a different
sensitivity analysis strategy it would
also be similarly intractable or might
it be that some of them are easier to
deal with i
it's not clear to me
that's a great question
this
marginalization or
the intractability really comes from
this
nested approach
where you want
the beta variable to be feasible for the
thing you're trying to estimate so i
think a different
identification or different estimation
approach in combination with different
choices for the sensitivity model would
have different tractability implications
so the intractability is introduced much
more by the
estimation approach that we're building
off of rather than the sensitivity model
per site it's just the combination of
estimation and the statistical summation
okay got it thank you
again
[Applause]
[Music]